jérôme pineau confondateur de clap le
collectif des livreurs autonome de paris
bonjour jérôme pineau à merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
bercy invite les salariés des secteurs
essentiels à travailler certains experts
appellent à un confinement total selon
vous les plates formes de commande en
ligne doivent-elles fermée pendant le
confinement est ce que c'est un secteur
essentiel
ben écoute et tout et tout est question
de savoir s'ils se faire livrer des
pizzas des burgers ou des baux boon ou
comme ce matin on a vu quelqu'un s'est
fait livrer un kinder bueno ci est ce
qu'on considère que c'est essentiel non
je pense pas il ya près de trente mille
livres en france il y en a il y en a un
certain pourcentage con con qui sont
déjà contaminés
on est sur une petite conversation avec
une vingtaine de cela en france est déjà
sur la vingtaine d'autres sont
contaminés ça veut dire que 10%
potentiellement des livreurs sont
contaminés aux contaminants je laisse
réfléchir le gouvernement à ça et qu'on
tenait par rapport à l'essence qualité
de ce qu'on transporte le ministère de
l'économie a établi un protocole de
livraison sans contact est ce que c'est
la bonne solution
ce serait une bonne solution si c'était
respecté sauf quand ça personne sur le
terrain c'est absolument pas respectée
on a vu notamment dans l'est des livres
aux éditions qui sont des cuisines des
cuisines multiples sur un site
on a vu que les gars ils attendent les
commandes les uns à côté des autres donc
ça absolument pas respecté ses plates
formes là se foutent complètement de
respecter ce genre de ce genre de mesure
à partir du moment où il faut qu elle il
faut qu'elle fasse du flux du chiffre et
en cas d'arrêt de votre activité
quelques quatre solutions à ce cas vous
vous proposez pour rémunérer les
livreurs
la solution c'est écoutez c'est simple
depuis le début de l'année l'urssaf à
toutes les factures des livreurs qui
passe par l parce que il ya un espèce de
des prélèvements à la source des places
en envoie les factures eau aux livreurs
et en même temps à la à l'urssaf pour
que leurs sacs puisse calculer les
cotisations puisse savoir qui déclare ou
pas donc l'urssaf létard à toutes nos
factures à partir de là elle sait qui
travaille qui a travaillé c'est
notamment ces deux derniers mois
nous on veut que les gens soient
indemnisées par rapport à ce qu'ils ont
travaillé c'était clair que les gens qui
sont à plein temps un système
forfaitaire les gens qui ont travaillé à
plein
un des musées de 1500 euros par mois et
des gens qui sont à temps partiel de
moitié c'était la préconisation qu'on a
envoyés notamment à saché ollier un
député de la république en marche de
façon à ce qu'il soit lui en contact
avec les plâtres avec les plans mais
qu'ils puissent négocier ça avec elle et
qui devrait prendre en charge ces
indemnisations l'état les plateformes
qui pour payer
écoutez l'état dans un premier temps
parce qu'on sait que ça ira plus vite
parce que si on attend les plateformes
on va attendre des mois et des mois
donc les gens vont devoir continuer à
aller travailler comme ils pourront
l'état dans un premier temps et ensuite
l'état pourra se retourner vers les
plateformes dont on sait maintenant
depuis quelques semaines que j'utilise
un système frauduleux de deux faux
travailleurs indépendants donc ça plus
ça je pense que l'état à toutes les
ficelles pour aller chercher de l'argent
comme l'a fait notamment dans le cadre
de la de la saisie de 3 millions sur les
comptes de des livres ou en attente d'un
procès au pénal
donc je veux dire c'est pas juste des
entreprises classiques on est sur des
entreprises frauduleuses s'est avéré
c'est constaté le conseil
constitutionnel a statué le conseil
la cour de cassation donc voilà on sait
où aller chercher l'argent parce que
c'est plate forme là on avec quelles
responsabilités quelles conséquences
également pour les restaurateurs
affiliés à sa plateforme et qui
continuent leurs activités
bah de toute façon on voit que sur le
terrain les restaurateurs qui avaient
donc fermer leur salle et laisser mourir
leur cuisine pour faire de la livraison
de toutes façons ferment les uns après
les autres
donc c'est pareil on va se retrouver
dans la rue avoir de moins en moins de
courses et si notre secteur est pas
arrêtée officiellement par le
gouvernement on pourra pas toucher ses
indemnités
les restaurateurs peu ils ont compris et
y est mais les patrons de restaurants
les salariés vont toucher des indemnités
ça ça a été décrétée pour nous il n'y a
rien donc si notre secteur ferme pas on
sera pas indemnisé il faut que m secteur
ferme pour qu'on soit comme tous les
autres travailleurs qui sont pas
essentiels indemnisés et pour les
livreurs diagnostiqué positif au coin
8,19 à ce qu'il ya des dispositions qui
ont déjà été mises en place alors les
plateformes indemnise hauteur de
notamment celui des livres ou ses 230
euros pour 12
20 euros par jour donc c'est ridicule
c'est ridicule c'est pas ça qui va qui
va leur permettre de rester chez eux
tranquillement à attendre la fin du
confinement qui pourrait durer à
plusieurs semaines encore merci d'avoir
répondu à une question a subtilement je
rappelle que vous êtes le co fondateur
de club le collectif des livreurs
autonome de paris